I ditched the USA
to go to this biohacking retreat
in Sayulita, Mexico for one week
and on our first day we sat in Temazcal
a traditional Mexican sweat lodge
it was treated like a psychedelic experience
facilitated by a Mexican native
the whole retreat felt
like a ceremony in itself
a container where I was able
to meet other like minded women
unlike anywhere else
and this time I was able
to bring my favourite human
during this week long adventure
I kept saying to myself you know
you're lucky if you meet
even one incredible person
every five years
and that's if you're lucky
but in this case
it's like meeting a lifetime
of your brothers and sisters
from previous lives
because everyone is already vetted
everyone already knows
what's going on in the world
and everyone's health is their
number one priority
most of these people also
heal themselves from chronic illness
because the medical system failed them
at one point most of these people
were probably vegan
the main things we all have in common
is the entrepreneurial drive
for freedom
and the desire to have more
like minded people in our lives
and this retreat was the
perfect container to facilitate that